all right hello my name is Mallory and I
really love dashboards and I'm so
excited to tell you guys all about them
so I am a data scientist I work full
time as a consultant for Amazon through
a company called Annika I was previously
at NPR and amplify education before that
and we're going to talk about dashboards
so I am kind of addicted to - words and
every time I make a project I put all my
analysis in a dashboard and my goal here
is to inspire some of you to love
dashboarding like I love dashboarding I
know all of you might you know maybe not
but it's kind of like a therapy that you
can insert in between the pain of
constant data manipulation and you get
to make something pretty so here we go
also this is a dashboard and I've got my
slide deck in a dashboard and you'll see
you can put dashboards in dashboards
I haven't I mean dashboards all the way
down you know alright so why bother so
first of all they're pretty and
organized so if you have a whole bunch
of stuff like a whole bunch of plots and
CSVs and let's say you have a set of
slides and some other HTML output and
you want to put this all this stuff
together
you should never email that stuff no one
wants to look at CSV use and pngs in
their email and things get lost and it's
terrible and you forget the last status
state of things and then somebody asks
you for something and you have to go
find the Pete you know the PNG that oh
my god it's just terrible so this is a
way that you can keep your stuff
organized and pretty in so
wait you know you can make things that
aren't dashboards you can make our
markdowns like regular notebooks but
it's a pretty easy transition as you'll
see to making it really pretty and you
can convert between the different
formats fairly easily
so it's risk free and there are
templates galore and by risk free I mean
so unlike when you're trying a new
modeling tool or a new package that
manipulates data you have to know what
you're doing and you have to check a lot
of stuff to make sure that what you
intended to do you actually achieved
that's goal but with dashboarding like
all you're doing is organizing your
stuff and making it pretty so you can
take someone's template and copy and
paste the CSS that they wrote and you
don't have to understand anything about
it but did it make your dashboard
prettier cool
you can use it so it's a very fake it
till you make it kind of thing you don't
have to understand anything and like you
just mess around and go oh okay that
blew everything up or all that made like
where's my output now so you really
don't have to know what you're doing
you're not gonna like mess up your
actual analysis it's just like a fun
like play space also - speaking of
templates galore all of this is on my
github everything all the tutorials
within it so my main contribution here
is not that I'm gonna be able to teach
you a whole bunch of stuff right now and
mostly like it trying to inspire you to
bother to go to the github onion you can
just take all the code and like put your
own data in it and then there you go
that's how it starts so I know this is a
bit controversial but with dashboards
you can have you know interactive stuff
like with HTML so unlike in powerpoints
or other still forms like PNG s in a
dashboard you can have everything
interactive like hover with like
information that pops up and you can do
so much more with an interact a single
interactive plot than you can with a
static one so yeah sorry Gigi but
we'll get there and to redeem myself you
get to use our so that's you know enough
said and it's flexible and reproducible
so just like with an hour markdown that
you could supply arguments and then
render the code you can do the same kind
of thing here so for example if you had
30 different podcasts and you wanted to
make a dashboard for each one of those
podcasts you could write one dashboard
script with some arguments and then have
a little render function that run and
I'll put a little loop around it and
then you could just build render and
publish 30 different dashboards with
just a single template pretty awesome
and best of all people will respect you
so I have to say there's like nothing
more satisfying in the world than when
you went some Python fan boys that
you've overheard talking about how R is
dead see your dashboards and then ask
you how you made it and you're like with
our okay so let's get to it so I have
created a stealth 12-step program to
quit emailing plots and CSVs I can't get
through all twelve steps today but I'll
try to get you at least part of the way
there and obviously I just wanted to
make it twelve steps like could have
made it some other number of steps like
ten probably was easier I had to kind of
work at it to get it into twelve but
basically you have your basic layout
actually making the dashboard layout is
not hard that's the easiest there's so
much information about that on the
internet we're gonna be using flex
dashboard as you'll see but and then
there's tables interactive datasets
interactive plots exporting your data
and then how to deal with CSS CSS which
mostly you'll copy-paste somebody else's
CSS like all the CSS templates that I
provided at the github and then your
branding hosting hosting is one that
you're gonna want to do if you're using
this for internally at your work you'll
have to talk to somebody that assists
admin find a sysadmin and if you don't
find somebody that runs the website of
your company
and then automating and replicating and
then maybe making it shiny which you can
totally do it is a very easy way to turn
something you can turn dashboards into
shiny quite easily all right so we're
gonna talk through the first five things
here basic way out printing interactive
datasets interactive plots and exporting
okay so first the basic layout so in
what with a regular RMD when you open up
a markdown it says output HTML output
HTML document so to just turn something
into a Flex dashboard in the most simple
fashion like all you would change is
from HTML document to Flex dashboard
flex dashboard so there's a couple extra
arguments you can add and my go-to for
my basic setup is to have the vertical
layout scroll so it doesn't try to
compress everything into a single screen
and instead lets you make a dashboard
you could scroll through and orientation
rows which I'll show you what what that
means so here's a basic layout
so this tab I'm actually this whole
thing is a Flex dashboard and this is a
page within the Flex dashboard that I've
built in like the main in the main
dashboard some of the other tabs are
like I've inserted within it anyway so
this basic layout
this is done with rows and how you can
tell is that there is that centerpiece
is not you don't have exact columns
lining up if you want an orientation
like this where something can span
across two columns then this is it's a
real orientation that you want so those
little things at the top are fun
built-in stuff that flex board a lab
that gives you this is a value box so it
lets you if you just want to give a
number it you can do this value box and
then little gauges and that can be fun
too and then also you can add favicons
which you can go nuts with these there's
a whole bunch of free ones and you can
make your own and that is you know just
makes things fun
so here's a basic layout nothing too
exciting this part is not hard resources
this parts easy so nothing's gonna shine
on that alright
so now printing we're print is simply
unacceptable because the point here is
to make things pretty you want someone
to want to look at this you want someone
to want to use it you want to like make
something where you can reference people
to the dashboard and then they'll go and
everything's pretty and nice and user
friendly and they're like why are you
beep a4x dashboarding tool when like you
can just spit these things out so man I
am so in love with this look at this
like this is in my CSS that's you know
this like star background of the it's so
wonderful
ok so now let's look at a few different
things that you can use to make your
printing prettier
alright so this with with base are if
you if you make no effort head iris
terrible this is ugly don't do it don't
make anyone look at that that not in a
dashboard so the easiest way to make a
print pretty is with print are so all I
did was load print are and then I ran
the exact same line headed iris and look
how much better that looks so much
better and I don't have to do anything I
just load the library done so that's
obviously a pretty simple solution to
print a lot prettier okay so now
descriptive stats so before I was just
showing if you rose and now I'm gonna
run a summary ok so again with base
summary iris there's so ugly don't do
that it's so easy to fix
oh look at that printer add it again
summary much better much better and you
still and you don't actually have to
change the line of code which is great
ok so you can achieve the same goal some
of you may have heard of cable you can
achieve the same goal with table but
it's just like a little bit more effort
you don't you know you can take your
coat
that you'd already written and it gave
ugly output and just add the library at
the top and then make it pretty output
this method you would have to actually
go in and change your code so that's
like more work alright and then now
stargazer
so this you this doesn't look good at
all
stargazer has a place but four summaries
just a basic summary stats that is way
too cramped
it's like painful to look at so another
one that's kind of cool that's getting
better but it doesn't have all its
capacities in our markdown is summary
tools but keep tabs on that because it
gives you a lot of cool information and
soon once somebody fixes it
it actually has like distribution like a
column that is has little plots of just
the distribution of that variable which
is super cool to have a plot inside of a
table but for now I'm kind of just like
that's an option but printer is also a
pretty simple option and once they get
the plots in there then I always start
using that alright so then for models
again terrible don't do that base are
that's a terrible printout and here
printer doesn't help us so printer won't
save you if you're trying to summarize
model output and this is where stargazer
winds stargazer stargazer model output
looks just like law tech model output
which you could use in it works for law
tech also in other formats but it works
with HTML so there's printing now I oh
yeah there's some links here that you're
gonna need to see for using stargazer
down here I specify which statistics I
want to show and you have to know the
little nickname for referencing them and
I have a slide here that gives you the
link because they can be hard to find
okay so now interactive data sets so
what am i what does this mean what is
different about what I was just showing
you and what I'm about to show you ok
look at this
look at this data set do you see this
hover like action and highlighting so
before we were just printing something a
summary I just wanted a few lines
there's no need to sort things I'm not
going to like I don't need to do
anything with this information or the
summary stats it's short it's simple I
don't have any intention of downloading
it whatever it's fine but if you have a
whole data set you would like to provide
the user with a data set this so easy
with data table with DT data table so
the levers DT and all I did data table
iris like one-liner you can make it a
lot cooler but look what it already does
this is so much better and you can
change this like 50 cool I could sort
things right on I could search for stuff
yes why don't you ever go up awesome and
then a little bit more advanced slightly
a few more keystrokes and now I can sort
and filter at the individual columns and
not just search and also what else can I
do I don't know four point nine you've
got search highlights all right this
looks like an actual dashboard this
looks like a thing in a dashboard that
somebody would pay for but you can just
build it yourself awesome and like that
is I mean I made it into two lines but
really that's like a one line of code so
pretty easy and the colors right here so
you can copy and paste it and insert
your data set whatever it is and it just
works and it's awesome all right so next
interactive plots huh okay so now that
we're not in PowerPoint anymore and
we're talking about dashboards and we
want everything to be interactive and
fun
our plot should be interactive and fun
too so we're going to take a look at hi
charter which is my favorite
plotting tool it's actually if once you
get good at GD plot you will find high
charter to be really quite similar pipes
and all I mean it's actual the actual
pipes not the pluses but let's take a
look okay so suppose somebody you know
you're making some some bar plot so this
is pretty simple you see
start with the data set I can pipe it in
do some manipulation and then just pipe
it into a chart I have I will reference
it basically go to my my github for more
details on this because I'm gonna have
to go kind of fast I just want to show
you what it can do and like that it's
not very hard so call them HKS a lot of
the syntax looks pretty similar to
ggplot and then look what you get I have
this thing this bar plot and I can hover
and I have information so you know when
somebody says oh that bar plot can you
put the totals at the top of the bars
you're like oh my god
and with this they're like fine done
like oh but also can you make it
separately - I want one with also just
2008 okay fine oh no but I also want mom
with also just to thought okay fine also
with just like one that's blank fine so
pretty awesome you can make a lot of
plots in one plot okay so now I'll show
you just kind of like skim through this
bubble plot that I've made here it also
has a hover action cool it's looking at
some star data and luminosity and
distance and you can scale the axis so
here I didn't actually log the X and the
y I just scaled well I did a logarithmic
scale on the x and y which is like if
there's pros and cons to that but in the
end if you've set if you're trying to
show someone something you're like
actually it's log X or log Y and then
they're like oh god I don't know how to
think in terms of logs here you've just
scaled the axis so that you seeing the
smaller it's as if it's logged but the
data itself is not logged and so people
tend to understand it a little bit more
if you're showing it to you know some
product manager or you're a director or
something and you can very easily add
colors in the same way that you're used
to with colorize so just pick a color
scheme assign with colorize and then add
the colors color equals color nice
so I colorized by distance of the stars
and then you can add access titles which
also it's very easy I show
you hear essentially come back to this
reference obviously I can't teach you hi
Carter in like two minutes and then
custom hypertext so obviously this is
like terrible Wow
I should at least round those numbers
but also what are those numbers
referring to so this is probably this is
a really really great component so you
can create custom hover text so you just
assign the X with Dec like the X is
going to be the name the Y is the value
and then you use that tool tip and you
can create custom tooltips and it's
really easy it's just like you copy
paste that and then just swap out the
you know names of columns and like it's
amazing this is like so this is the all
it took this code to do this make this
whole thing and everything up here is
just colors and assigning a a custom
hover text and then that's the all it
takes to get you that plot so pretty
cool alright last thing is oh yeah I
also want to say of course there is also
leaflet which is great for making
interactive maps digraphs this for a
time series and plotly which if you
really can't let go of GG plots you can
use plot leaf or as a as a wrapper
okay so exporting last thing to like
really make your dashboard super useful
so that when you send it over to someone
they they don't have to come back to you
you go go to the dashboard it's all
there so you can and export the data and
the plots from your dashboard so let's
go to the exporting tab here okay so
this one is a Flex dashboard in a Flex
dashboard nice so here for oopsies for
hi charter it actually that is it's a
little bit tricky but I wrote I found I
figured out how to do it so there's a
simple HC exporting which is built-in
but it doesn't work I found that it
and so there's this line of code that
defines some things I have a script a
separate script in there you just source
it and then you can export so you don't
have to go search the internet like I
did you can just source that script and
then voila in the corner you can export
the images or the or the data whatever
you want and then with data table same
thing I've supplied the code here for
exporting and then your the download
button and you can download the data
awesome so that they have the data and
the plots and whatever they want and
they don't have to come back to you and
bother you while you're working on your
next data manipulation or dashboard so
I'm out of time but basically keep it
simple organized and explore things so
start with somebody else to CSS keep
things organized and don't make changes
that you don't know how to undo and
every time you make a project try
something now and that's it
[Applause]